in this goodie bag we'll be exploring
atomic packing and solids through the
cubic bravia lattices
we'll make three ball and stick models
of different cubic unit cells
for this you will need 31 balls and 44
sticks
24 for fcc 12 for sc and 8 for bcc
if you don't have a fancy crystal
modeling kit like this any ball and
stick equivalents will work
a delicious alternative would be using
toothpicks and marshmallows
the objective of the goodie bag is to
explore the different structures of
crystalline materials
as you build the models consider how
many nearest neighbors an atom has in an
sc
a bcc and an fcc crystal so now we're
going to construct our bravais lattices
we'll start with simple cubic begin by
taking
eight balls and connecting them with
sticks such that each ball
sits at the corner of a cube
then for body centered cubic we're going
to start with a single ball
in the center of a cube and connect to
eight other balls at the corners with
sticks
for face center cubic is going to be a
little more involved
we'll start with the corner of a cube
and form tetrahedra
to other balls which themselves will
form tetrahedra
to another corner of a cube if we
iterate through this process
we eventually end up with a full face
centered cubic lattice
we've now constructed three ball and
stick models of cubic bravia lattices
the simple cubic lattice has atoms at
each of the eight corners of the unit
cell
the body centered cubic lattice has an
additional atom in the body center of
the unit
cell and the face centered cubic lattice
has an additional atom in each of the
six
face centers of the unit cell each of
these lattices has a different
coordination number
that is an atom in each lattice has a
different number of nearest neighbors
if we imagine these atoms as hard
spheres
rather than this ball and stick model we
can see that each lattice will also have
a different atomic packing factor
that is each lattice will have a
different
volume of space occupied in the unit
cell
in general the coordination number of a
lattice
correlates with atomic packing factor
which itself correlates with stability
that's why we don't often find simple
cubic metallic solids in nature